vous avez été interrogé cette après-midi
sur le réseau social chinois Tik Tok et
notamment le rapport de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat est-ce que le
gouvernement prévoit des sanctions
vis-à-vis de ce réseau social si jamais
à la fin de l'année il ne respecte pas
ses obligations notamment en matière de
transparence mais vous savez le droit
européen avec le règlement sur les
services numériques que la France
apportait l'année dernière à
l'initiative du Président de la
République prévoit des sanctions très
lourdes à l'encontre des grandes
plateformes comme Tik Tok qui ne
respecteront pas leurs obligations de
transparence de loyauté de protection de
leurs utilisateurs de protection de la
sécurité publique ces amendes elles
peuvent aller jusqu'à 6% du chiffre
d'affaires c'est 600 millions d'euros
pour Tik Tok voire même au bannissement
de l'Union européenne en cas de
manquement répété et nous serons
vigilants à ce que la Commission
européenne puisse bien infliger ses
sanctions si effectivement Tik Tok n'est
pas au rendez-vous de ces nouvelles
obligations puisqu'elles rentrent en
vigueur le 25 août prochain alors on va
aborder la stratégie du gouvernement en
cas de nouvelles violences
urbaines notamment
toujours des festivités du 14 juillet si
jamais c'est violence éclatent de
nouveau et ce que le gouvernement
prendra des mesures supplémentaires pour
éviter notamment un emballement sur les
sur les réseaux sociaux avec le mise de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin nous avons
convoqué la demande du Président de la
République les principales plateformes
de réseaux sociaux le vendredi 30 juin
pour les rappeler à leurs obligations
devant la loi le retrait des contenus
illicites qu'on leur signale les
réponses aux réquisition de l'autorité
judiciaire pour pouvoir mener les
enquêtes mais on leur a aussi demandé
d'être particulièrement vigilante à leur
fonctionnalités qui ont pu être dévoyées
au profit de rassemblement violent le
résultat c'est que ce sont des milliers
de contenus qui ont été retirés des
centaines de comptes qui ont été
supprimés des dizaines de réquisitions
qui qui ont été traitées et le résultat
c'est que on voit d'ores et déjà dans
des dizaines de départements des
condamnations y compris à la des peines
de prison tomber pour des faits de haine
ou de d'incitation à la haine en ligne
pendant le premier épisode des notes
donc on reste évidemment
particulièrement pendant le week-end du
14 juillet en cas d'appel à la violence
sur les réseaux de la part de mineurs
est-ce que la responsabilité parentale
également engagée il y a une loi qui
vient d'être adoptée par le Sénat après
avoir été adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale qui va conditionner
l'inscription des mineurs sur les
réseaux sociaux lorsqu'ils ont moins de
15 ans au recueil par la plateforme du
consentement de leur parent ce sera une
manière de responsabiliser les parents
puisque il faudra qu'ils puissent donner
leur consentement et donc être au
courant de l'inscription à minima de
leur enfant sur les réseaux sociaux et
donc il y aura pas forcément de
sanctions en cas d'appel à la violence
de mineur sur les réseaux sociaux pour
les parents sur les régimes de sanctions
le garde des soins a eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur le sujet la première
ministre également il y a des réflexions
sur la manière de mieux responsabiliser
les les parents mais je leur laisse le
soin de d'annoncer le résultat de ces
travaux lorsqu'ils auront abouti alors
justement dans cette réflexion vous avez
mené un groupe de travail à partir
d'aujourd'hui entre les parlementaires
sur ce lien entre violences urbaines et
réseaux sociaux quelle est le but
comment ça va fonctionner est-ce que la
majorité de droite du Sénat ils
participent le président de la
République a souhaité qu'on puisse froid
analyser la contribution des réseaux
sociaux à la formation des
rassemblements violents et que on évalue
ce qui dans le droit français dans le
droit européen nous permet de nous
prémunir contre ce type de dévoiement
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me suis
engagé la semaine dernière à former un
groupe de travail transpartisans à
parité de députés et de sénateurs pour
qu'on puisse réfléchir travailler
pendant l'été et qu'à l'occasion de
l'examen à l'Assemblée nationale du
projet de loi que je porte adopter la
semaine dernière à l'unanimité du Sénat
on puisse le cas échéant intégrer des
dispositions en nouvelles ce groupe de
travail va se réunir dans une heure à
Bercy il intègre des parlementaires
issus toute sensibilité y compris
évidemment les LR du Sénat dont le
rapporteur Patrick Chase
[Musique]